Cosmetic surgery is growing more popular,
worldwide.
More than 87 percent of all plastic surgery
is performed on women, and the number one
is breast augmentation.
Let's bust this wide open.
In the 1940s, Japanese prostitutes would inject
paraffin or sponge into their breasts to increase
their bust line and attract American soldiers
during World War II.
Then, in 1962, the first silicone breast implantation
was performed in Houston, Texas.
Now, 50 years later,.
In 2013, there were more than 23 million surgical
and nonsurgical cosmetic procedures performed
worldwide and the most common, at 1.77 million,
were breast implant surgeries!
Breasts are a collection of fat, milk-producing
lobules, lymph nodes, and connective tissues.
No two are alike, even on the same person!
They sit on top of pectoral muscles, over
the ribs and, as you likely know, exist for
breast feeding infants, but have other social
purposes as well.
They're continually developing until the age
of 22, and their size is both genetically
and environmentally determined; hormone or
chemical exposure, diet and genetics will
all affect their size, but in the end, some
augment their breast tissue with a prosthetic
implant.
In the US, most implants are made of a contoured
or round synthetic polymer called elastomer.
The sizes are measured in cubic centimeters,
and each cup-size is 175 to 200 ccs of fluid.
In 2012, 72 percent contained silicone, and
28 percent a sterile saline solution -- a
basic medical grade salt water.
Silicone was banned by the FDA from 1992 because
of concerns over the implant rupturing, but
in 2006 the ban was lifted after significant
testing.
There are three types of breast implant surgeries.
Under the breast tissue alone, MOSTLY under
the pectoralis major muscle and ENTIRELY under
the pectoralis major.
The implant can be inserted through an incision
around the areola incision to limit scar tissue,
in the crease of the breast for when the crease
needs moving anyway, through the armpit, to
avoid breast scarring or damage, or even through
the belly button!
Once inserted the implants are inflated with
fluid, positioned, and voila!
It's a surgery, so it takes time for body
has to heal, and patients must essentially
do physical therapy during that process.
The human body doesn't enjoy having things
inserted into it, so as it heals the immune
system will begin creating scar tissue around
the implant.
A new method for silicone implants from the
UK uses a textured surface on the exterior
of the implant which mimics other surfaces
in the body, but scar tissues are pretty much
inevitable.
Overall, if both the surgeon and patient do
their jobs properly, the breasts will look
entirely natural.
If not, capsular contracture will occur, which
is when the scar tissue causes a stiff, unnatural
look.
A good boob job is like a good wig -- you
don't notice the good ones...
Though 1-2 percent of implants fail each year,
breast implants shouldn't harm the body any
more than any other implanted medical prosthesis.
If they DO rupture the scar tissue surrounding
the implant could keep it intact for a while;
saline can be absorbed by the body, and the
FDA says silicone won't harm the body, cause
cancer or damage tissues in any way.
Either way surgery would be involved to remove
the implant or replace it.
FYI: NO, they don't pop on airplanes, and
can even be run over by a car to test their
durability.
People undergo breast augmentation for MANY
reasons: postmastectomy reconstruction, congenital
deformations, uneven breast development, post-breastfeeding
collapse, or simply by choice for their own
positive body image, self-esteem or confidence
or gender reassignment surgeries!
In fact, the second most common plastic surgery
in the world for MEN is Breast Reduction for
Gynecomastia.
Some men get breast augmentation too.
Surgeons are trained to screen for body dysmorphic
disorders in their patients, and they know
any procedure is part of a conversation.
Studies have correlated breast augmentation
electees to increases in suicide over 10 years,
as well as self-esteem issues, but the bottom
line is: it's your body, your choice.